David bla ripped me off like I've been
on the water for 24 hours and he
borrowed that which is totally cool like
God bless him last year I went to go see
his show and I was like dude I apologize
for anything that might have offended
you and I had a beautiful beautiful ring
like 20 G's and I said this is for you
let's build a friendship and he's like I
can't accept this and then he called
this friend over I was like hey let's
put it in a museum you could do whatever
you want that I'm giving it to you I was
like well I gave it to David yeah
if he wants to give it to you that's his
business and then I was like hey let's
do a picture and he's like oh I can't do
a picture with just you and me alone
it's like dude grow up like we're both
adults we both have children I had a kid
with cancer you think he would say hey
Chris thanks for the ring or whatever I
texted him and I was like hey man happy
Father's Day thanks for having us at the
show and uh never responded so I was
like cool dude I wish him the best life
is too short man and when you have a kid
with cancer you realize how fragile life
is